Thank you.
Hello everyone I am Peter, I am hoping that
you are still awake, this is the post lunch
crowd I am aware of that.
This guy on Twitter, even though my nickname
is actually 23 years old I was very late to
Twitter so I have the underscores.
I work at a company called Citryx Copenhagen
on a produced called Podio, where I am the
front-end lead very short for the history
buffs amongst you Podio is a hyper card for
the web, software service thing plus a bit
of collaboration on top of that.
I have also been an organiser of Copenhagen.js
for a couple of years, some of you might recognise
yourself on this image, if you want to leave
it there for a minute.
If you have ever heard about me from the open
source circle you might have heard of my project
called Assetgraph which is yet another build
tool with a different approach and I can't
stop talking about it so if you want to learn
about this poke me in one of the breaks and
find me.
This is yet another build tooling talk but
this one is specific to transpiler so in case
you don't no what a transpiler is it's a compiler
instead of compiling source code into machine
code it compiles it into a different type
of source code.
In this case on your right hand side which
is over here for you yes, is the machine code
which in our case is CSS HTML JavaScript and
things like that.
On the left hand which is really confusing
when it's opposite, you have the source code
that you would like to write, this is your
ES6, Sass, stuff like that.
Any time in this talk when I mention transpiler
or transpiling you can substitue for any of
these in your mind, Saas, CoffeeScript, Babel,
TypeScript, Markdown or whatever.
Odds are some of you have used one of these.
So these are all transpilers.
This talk is about why transpiling is a problem.
I don't have a problem with transpilers there
was, transpilers are really awesome unix type
tools which take 1 or more inputs and give
you one output and that is actually really
simple and really good.
The problem I have is with one of the side
affects that come with some of the build systems
that people use when they integrate transpilers
into their work.
The primary culprit here is the build artefact.
The build artefact is the thing that your
browser
consumes or that other tools consume it's
again your CSS, JavaScript, your HTML.
Build artefacts have a transient nature, they
are not the thing we're actually interested
in, but they are the thing that we need to
produce in order for the machine to understand
what we're doing.
So this means that we want build the artefacts
but primarily for consumption we're not really
interested in storing them until we actually
want to deploy our websites.
This gives us a weird duality and gives us
some problems with work field setups, let
do a workflow set up of a project right now
so I can show you why this complex.
So first of all, the simplest possible way
you can do transpiling is you transpile your
source code into the target code in the same
directory.
They are sibling files, in this case you have
your main Sass final which gets compiled into
your main CSS file it's a sibling it's easy
to understand you know where to find your
code.
So we're not interested in the build artefacts
so let's add and ignore for CSS files in our
source directory so we don't version control
them anymore.
This is what most people do it's easiest to
main then.
Now the first problem arrives because eventually
because the code that we produce as build
art facts is the same code we might also write
in other cases, you might have other CSS files
in your directory your source directory.
These might also be JavaScript files it's
completely valid to have files of the extension
that the browser consumes in your source directory.
So if you start ignoring them you are in a
world of pain.
So we don't do this.
This is a bad idea.
What most people have come up with is a set
up where you have your app and your main Sass
file you compile into a directory called artefact.
Or temp I think most people use underscore
temp in yeoman set up at least your main CCSS
resides here.
You can very easily ignore from version control
all your build artefacts you simple ignore
the folder where they exist.
This is pretty nice, but now you URL are sort
of broken because the source code is not actually
where you expect to it be it's in a different
directory it might even be in a directory
outside of your web route.
So, in order to deal with this, people have
come up with this nice set up where you can
add a piece of middleware to your web server
this will know about the existence of a build
artefacts in a different directory.
In the first we get we see that the web server
is looking for main.CSS in the directory,
then looking for index.HTML in the artefacts
directory, it might not actually be a transpiled
build artefact.
So when it guess 404 it falls back to original
source directory then gets a correct hit on
index.HTML.
Then we have a piece of middleware that needs
to know something about your workflow set
up.
So next of all you probably want to somehow
trigger your builds get it tedious to manually
run these tasks just as you don't like refreshing
your browser you probably don't like running
mate or Grunt whatever you use.
Usually people set up file watching they watch
all the CSS files all the Sass files it should
have been in the source directory, and whenever
you have a
source file increment whenever you make a
change, you trigger the transpiled task we
set up before then you get your updated build
artefact.
While we're added usually people set up library
loading so whenever build artefact gets updated
the browser will also update so you can see
your changes.
This is pretty nice but in order to orchestrate
this now you have a task, now you have a web
server that needs to know about things, now
you have a file watcher you have a library
loader, this is a lot to do manually so you
probably want to have some sort of task runner
to orchestrate all of these things at the
same time.
So people in here probably used at some point
in time Grunt, Gulp, Broccoli, Make even you
can do that.
That's about it.
For workflow set up for CSS, but these days
we're not only transpiling CSS, we're also
transpiling JavaScript.
JavaScript is consumed by more consumers than
just the browser or your build system.
So suddenly we need to also think about how
does this build artefact integrate or how
does my workflow tooling integrate with all
the other consumers of my build artefact.
How does the task runner understand ES6, how
does my production bundler understand ES6
how does my test framework understand it.
The solution for these are usually oh you
just have each of these tool implement a plug-in
framework so you can use Babel plug-in for
you linter and you middleware and task runner
and production bundler and test framework
and your module loader and for anything else
that might be touching your source code.
You need a plug-in for each of these for each
of the types of languages you want to transpile,
just start multiplying the amount of plug-ins
you need.
So some people think this is okay, the word
I use for it is "complex."
I think this is way too complex but don't
worry there's a solution for this complexity,
obviously you don't want to set up a system
like this by hand every time you create anew
project, so we simply say oh we can order
generate it then it's easy.
Because I only need to run one command, but
this is easy it's not simple.
It's easy but creates a lot of complexity.
The problem is when anything goes wrong, in
this set up, imagine you're a newbie, you
are sitting in a code dojo and somebody tells
you to run a webapp and something goes wrong
and all you see is this.
Your first question is, how does it work?
Why is it even set up in that way?
You might have been able to follow me right
here, because you have all done this before,
you have all felt the pain, the kind of understand
which moving parts are here, but a new newbie
doesn't a this a big problem.
Whenever I say workflow tool is complex there's
always at least one person in the room that
says "oh you know Peter my set up is special,
my set up has legacy.
My set up has complexity" so we need this
complexity.
We need it.
I promised Peter Fantazi(?) to say people
who say this are doing it wrong, you're doing
it wrong if you ever said this you need complexity.
You don't need complexity you need ability.
The ability is what your tools are supposed
to give you, they are not supposed to give
you complexity.
The ideal tool gives you maximum ability and
minimum complexity, also called simplicity.
So what we should strive for is to build tools
that are simple.
So let's figure out what these moving parts
are, what are the important attributes of
transpiling that we actually want in, in order
to gain this ability, then recompose them
in a way so we can actually gain this ability
with minimum complex overhead so that a new
person is able to say I want to use transpiler
but don't want to buy into a massive ecosystem,
I want this one ability to transpile and nothing
else.
Maybe I don't even want a web server.
So the things I have come up with, this might
not be a complete list, some of these might
also and not necessarily have to be there
but it's a good guideline right?
I think in order to avoid this idiocy of having
a million transpiled plug-ins for everything,
we should figure out a way to have a tool
that can actually just handle all types of
transpilers, let's figure out how to unify
that a single transpiler can transpile more
than one thing, we can clean up MPM, we don't
need all the plug-ins we don't need that any
more, let's figure out how to do this.
Needs a good API, integrate with other tools,
the best APII can come up with is a file system,
because any tool can interact with a file
system.
It should be stand alone and shouldn't impose
a big, nasty ecosystem on you, it should be
doing on-demand transpilation, so some task
runners are actually not doing that right
now, going to come back to that.
Should keep URLs valid, if you can trace a
URL from your browser down directly to your
source code and find your files on disk that
makes everything more simple.
I think it should be nice, it should have
all the nice things that everybody wants to
have, sources maps, auto prefixes, caching,
it should simply understand what needs to
be done at the time you need it to be done.
With that also comes, there should be a simple
mental model if you can't explain how this
tool works within one or two sentences, then
it's probably too much.
So, let's see how the current set up stacks
up, I'm a bit critical here so maybe more
check marks over here.
Task runners, they definitely handle all types
of transpilers with a lot of plug-ins which
I don't like, give us source maps, auto prefixing
caching things like that, some of them have
a really, really horrible API, most of them
actually.
They are definitely not stand alone, they
do by definition impose an ecosystem that
we have to work within, you cannot, like my
- that runs on file systems cannot consume
a Gulf stream, transpilers transpile on file
change, they also transpile things that you
might not actually be using at the moment,
that's a lot of waste of resource cycles fright
there, don't keep URLs valid, at least if
you have a set up where you have your built
artefacts outside of your web route, they
definitely have a lot of configuration, that's
the primary things that these task runners
have and I don't think they're simple.
Now, I don't want to hate on task runners,
I think that task runners are actually instrumental
to getting us to where we are.
I think they have created a very stable foundation
to develop tools on and I think we should
thank them for that, but I also think that
they have been an incremental
optimisation towards a local optimum, I think
we can maybe do a leap and figure out if there
is a more optimal way to do this.
One of the concepts that I've been thinking
about is control flow with this, most of these
task runners are based on a control flow that
says, whenever you change your source code
I'm doing some work and then I might tell
you about it.
It's actually possible to reverse these there
are a few points in this set up where you
can actually hook in and do the opposite,
you can figure out whenever somebody wants
to consume an asset and then you can intercept
that and then you can do something about it.
So one of the things that I've been using
instead of using a task runner for transpiling
is a piece of middleware, this sits in my
express server and by having this ability
to intercept requests you can integrate all
types of transpilers, you can figure out the
browser wants this, I'll just go and fetch,
it also reduces the configuration, because
I don't need to configure a path, the browser
will tell me the path it wants and I can read
it from the file system here, do the changes,
map it, or prefix it and keep the URLs valid,
it's kind of simple to understand, it's a
pipeline and on the way through some work
is done, right, but it's missing some check
points.
Not all my tools are consuming HTTP, that's
a problem, so I still need to have all these
plug-ins for command line tools and I still
get all the complexity of having these plug-ins.
So, I've thought a lot about this idea and
last year on, on this very stage actually,
on this spot, Mattheus was demoing Wiki streamed
and stuff, he was using a technology that
was really cool, instead of explaining a lot
about that, I'd like to jump into a demo and
show you what I'm able to do by using this
idea that he gave me.
So I'll jump into my console, this is big
enough text, looks good.
New be developer, just at out of the coding
dojo.
I have a sources folder with my awesome website,
it's really down-to-earth, hello world, index
HTML, stuff like that.
I can show you here, it looks like this, hello
JSConf.eu, it has a Cat image, every good
website should have a Cat image, I can open
this thing and you can see it.
It's a good example of a starter website I
have, a heading, "Hello world", I've given
it a colour so I can interact with things,
a Cat image, it's always good for learning
and I wrote it a bit, so again I can interact
with things.
So one year later I'm slightly more experienced
webpage developer and now I'm ready to take
on the concept of an abstraction.
So, what I would like to do, is I would like
to be able to abstract my colour into a variable.
So I ask someone and everybody in the room
here would probably say I need SASS.
So my sources file, my main file, I thought
I would open it, I've already prepared a bit,
I'm really, really bad at live coding, I create
the colour, no longer purple, but hot pink,
a bit closer to the JSConf.eu colour, now
the heading should be hot pink, right.
There is one more thing I need to do in order
to make this SASS, I need to move my file
from sources main dot CSS, to main dot - it
means when I reload my page, in this case
it doesn't work, it doesn't work because I've
moved the file and it doesn't see the file
at all.
Now I'm ready to integrate my transpiler,
right.
So this is where I have a tool that I'd like
to demonstration for you, the tool is called
fusile, a command line tool, I would tell
it, can you create a directory call, "DEV",
before you do this you can see there isn't
one, when I run the command it tells me I've
run some transpilers, babel, the done then
I have those in my node modules, you will
see there is a directory here, with kind of
a weird, file size, summary, that doesn't
quite make sense, but it's called 'DEV', if
you see the tree of the sources files compared
to the tree of the DEV files, they look kind
of similar, right, they contain pretty much
the same files, except for one difference,
in my sources directory, main CSS, target
directory, DEV directory it's called main.
CSS, what did it do, I can show you what it
did.
It actually compiled the SASS for me, immediately.
What I just did here I consumed the - on command
it compiled the SASS for me, using the colour
variable, applied auto brief fixing and sources
mapping, if I open this awesome webpage again,
it's hot pink and has the rotation and everything,
it's pretty awesome.
This does not only work for, for SASS, it
also works for, probably, hello world file,
an ES 6 syntax file, I can show you the output
of that, when I read it from the DEV directory
and it's compiled it.
It's pretty cool, I ran this one command line
tool, this configuration and it does the right
thing for me.
So the project is called fusile, it has the
same properties of the express middleware
that I went through before, but it also checks
the two other boxes I think, good API, file
system API, any other tool can consumer there
is, Linter, tester, you don't need a web server
that's clever any more, Python Apache it doesn't
need to be spare for your application, it
stands alone, I only know how to programme
node, if you know how to write this in C,
come poke me and we can do that.
Behind the scenes it's using library called
Fuse, file system in user space, it's actually
just mounting this virtual directory and when
I read the files I can intercept the things
just like the middleware and do work to them,
inside it's a basic streaming pipeline like
in gulp if you do transpiling.
So it's an open sources project, it is publicly
available and it is on MPM, on version 103
or something.
It's not entirely well tested, but it is definitely
development-ready, I would love for you to
go in and try this out and see if you can
make it work for your set up, I'm definitely
going to make this work on my work set up,
I want these tools to succeed or at least
the idea to succeed.
So, look this up, give me some feedback and
chat me up in the break and I can tell you
more about it, but I want to leave you with
this, this is not only about the single tool,
it's about the concept of tools.
I want you to remember that tools are there
to provide ability and you should reject any
complexity that they add, or at least question
it all the time.
You should demand simplicity.
This is what tooling is all about, so I think
you should look through your text, see what
things do you have that actually don't give
you any benefits, figure out how they can
be improved.
If you can't do-it-yourself, ask on Twitter,
I have this problem, how can we improve it.
I think this is the way to move tooling forward,
I would really like to give the next generation
of
web developers an easier starting point than
we have, I don't want anybody mess we that
the amount of configuration it takes to set
this up manually.
My slides are here, you can follow me here
and occasionally blog on this URL, I want
to thank you for listening to me.
.